We the product of three and a half
billion years of intimate relationships.
So you're not just going
to step outside of that
from a different planet,
right?
Just get down to the fact that that's
part of like fit and you know you want to
have an intimate relationship and I think
one that's longer lasting because you
have your story and it's unfolding in
your partner has her or his story and it's
unfolding and then you weave
those together like a road,
you know,
and that makes the story much,
much,
much stronger and it gives
you some continuity but you
like it gives you a past,
it's stable and it gives you a presence
that's free on it gives you a future
that's,
it's,
it's solid and dependable.
It's something that you can rely on when
everything around you is moving up and
down far too rapidly.
And so you want to solve that problem.
You know what you want to have you and
maybe you want to take one sort of do you
want to have an intimate
relationship with?
It's probably not a pushover.
You want someone to give you
a good slap when you need one,
which is probably like six or seven
times a day just to ask for one,
right?
When you wake up in the morning,
that's what you should do.
You should turn to your wife and say,
your boss is just sloppy right
now because doesn't deserve it.
And so you want someone like that
and then slap him a little better.
Then you have some respect
for them too because you,
you know,
you've tried something,
a little trick that you think
I can get away with this.
And it's like,
wow,
did you I'm there.
[inaudible]
hey man,
you think,
well,
what do you do about temptation?
You know,
succumb to it.
That's the wrong answer.
What is the reason for that?
You know,
cause I can say what you know,
you shouldn't succumb to temptation.
There's sort of a preachy finger waving,
thinking that it was all done with that.
But that's not the,
what are the things I've learned about
ethical behavior is the reason you should
act ethically because
there wasn't anything bad,
but you could do like it's,
it's bad for you and for the future use
and it's better for your family and it's
better for everyone around you.
It's better.
It's not that you shouldn't do it,
that's wheat and you
will rebel against that.
Like who says I shouldn't do that?
That's not helpful.
It's like,
no,
you,
you want to be sensible about this.
You know?
Well,
why not take cocaine all the time?
I mean it's a real cost.
And the psychologist,
how often have this sort of thing
backwards because psychologists,
no,
I trying to tie themselves
up with knots thinking,
well,
why are people addicted?
So like what sort of
stupid question is that?
Tried your substance of choice.
You don't bloody well why
people are addicted to it.
It's really fun.
Rid of your anxiety.
You don't worry.
You know,
it's like,
it's,
it's something and you
can get isolated rats.
It didn't fit to Pokemon.
You don't time flat.
So there's no mystery about addiction.
The beneficiary is why aren't you
addicted to doing impulsive things all the
time?
Some of you probably are,
but,
but the problem is,
you know what the
consequences of that are.
It's a very short trip down hill and
it's because what you're doing is
maximizing pleasure in the moment,
but for going stability
and achievement and,
and everything's solid really
the medium to long term.
And so it's a pleasurable degenerated
came and you had definitely a terrible
place if that happens.
So you have to figure out how to regulate
temptation because it'll offer you and
that doesn't work.
So you know,
you have to regulate your
alcoholic take if you have to be.
Some of the really likes alcohol,
if you're into recreational drugs
or casual sex or anything like that,
or pornography,
all these places that you could slide
into that maximize immediate reward but
costs you in the long run.
You have to have strategy for that.
It's like,
why should I drink every night?
You need a reason for that.
And the answer is something like
it's gotta be something like,
I got better things to do.
That's the right answer.
I've got better things to do than that.
So,
and then what else do you need to know?
What are you going to
do with your life folks?
I get work and I don't mean hobby Jesus.
That's bad.
That's a bad way of thinking about it.
Like it's good if you have a hobby,
but that isn't what you think about
doing with your time outside of work.
It's like that's your life.
It's like what meaningful and productive
engagements are you going to set up for
yourself so that so that you're so
that you can tolerate your existence.
You know,
because one of the things the existential
psychologist pointed out the 1950s and
they were sort of suffering from,
what would you call it,
cognitive aftermath of World War II and
all the horrors that were revealed the
World War Two is that they're,
their realization was that human
beings owned something like a debt to
existence.
You know you have to pay the price for
your wretched existence and the pay that
price property.
You have to be doing something noble and
worthwhile and some of that's going to
be your career and your relationship
with your family and all that,
but you need to have a vision
for what it is that you're up to.
When you're not otherwise engaged,
what is it that you could be doing in
the world that would be worth getting up
for even when you're not well,
even when you're suffering,
even when someone close to you has died,
right?
Even in the depths of tragedy,
what is it that you are going
to engage yourself with?
It makes you think,
God dammit,
man,
this is a rough day,
but I'm getting the hell out of India.
That's not being happy,
right?
This way more than being happy.
This is what you do when you're not happy,
and that happens to a lot in your life
and you need an answer to that question
for the times when things are really damp
and dread and so you need to know what
you wear.
What are the,
where you're situated yourself.
One thing you can think of
is that while you could,
you could think about trying to make the
world a slightly less miserable place.
You know,
that's not a bad place to start
if you don't know what to do.
And there's lots of things out there
that aren't very good that you could
probably help a little bit
if you got your act together.
And so if you don't know what to do,
you can take,
well you don't,
there's a problem out there.
The whatever problem comes
to mind for you to take.
Well I can probably dare trying to solve
that at a small level badly so that I
get better at it.
And then,
you know,
when,
when things are falling apart around me,
I can hit me say,
look,
I've got this and this is
how I'm contributing and
that's a killer that you can
rest on when things are falling apart.
It need that.
And so
education,
so like,
okay,
well you don't,
you don't,
you don't do enough.
Obviously if that's a bad thing because
the world's complicated and the more you
know,
the less it's going to flap you horribly.
And so it's good to educate yourself.
So you might have a plan for that too so
that you can be a little bit more than
you are everyday.
And so I wrote a little about that too,
which was comparing yourself to who
you were yesterday and not to who,
who someone else's today,
which I wrote that rule very carefully
because you need to have a name and if
you have any infant stuff,
people are going to be
better at that than you.
And then you get all emptiness about it.
And not only entities,
but pretty hard on yourself because like
you're just not where you should be in
relationship to that aim.
And that can make you very
bitter displeased with the world.
But it's not a good way of
looking at it that it's,
it's even though you need
that value structure,
you needed up,
you need people who are above.
You need to,
because at least their
targets for emulation.
But you can always fake.
Well,
you know,
here I am now in my wretched
form and without my false,
uh,
tomorrow I could be one 10th of 1% better.
That's pretty good thing,
you know,
because you've got yourself
as the target and you know,
you can be slightly better than you are.
And then as you do that,
and that does make you bitter or resentful
to notice that you could be slightly
better than you are.
It's actually kind of hopeful,
you know,
because,
well that's a pathway to improvement
and so that's a good thing.
And so you just started to do that as a
meaningful way of engaging in the world.
Okay.
That's a good thing to do
with your time outside of her.
So anyways,
I laid all this out and this writing
program and so then the kids would write
their plan and it was really interesting
watching this because this just blew me
away.
It was like,
okay,
I don't know how to describe it either.
It's like you don't,
you know,
when you look back at the past,
you see the people had huge blind
spots in their culture and you thought,
well how the hell can people not
notice that that was the case,
you know,
but here's something we don't do.
These students,
they have been in school
for like 60 years,
you know,
and they were pretty
top of the rug students,
smart,
hardworking,
most of them,
the vast majority of it,
cause the u of t is actually a
very conservative institution.
There's a lot of children are
first generation immigrants
there and they're like
pretty desperate about the job market
and they're hitting their books pretty
hard.
So these are kids who have
their eye on the prize mostly.
No one had ever sat them down in their
entire life and ask them to spend like an
hour writing what sort of and they
want it to be and why you ain't go,
what the hell?
What's going on with that?
It's like how could we possibly have
constructed an education system that would
just spent 15 years trying to help
people become educated and never once get
them to think hard about who the hell
they want it to be up to justify that.
And you need to justify it,
right?
Because imagine you lay out a path
and then you get all doubtful about it
because you will,
especially if it's a difficult
path and you run into challenges,
know that you're all done.
All that potential you have for thought.
He's going to go after your planning
like mad and try to bring you down.
That's your doubts.
It's like you need some
arguments for those doubts.
You need like six reasons why
what you're doing is a good idea.
So when those doubts come up,
you can say,
no,
that's wrong.
I'm doing this cause I got these six
reasons that I'm doing this because I
thought it all the way down to the bottom.
And if someone gets in your
way in an inappropriate way,
it's the same thing.
And if you have six reasons
for what you're doing,
no one will ever stop you
because they'll Jack Day,
well,
why aren't you doing that?
He said,
well,
I don't know.
It's like you lose you've and you say,
well,
here's the reason.
And they say,
well,
how do you justify that?
And you go,
well,
I have this reason.
And then they say,
well,
you're a pretty smart,
how do you justify that?
And you have two other reasons isn't.
Then they get angry and go away
and you went for the [inaudible] gets
right.
This as well as part of
this narrative courts.
And so again,
they're writing like math,
like 15,000 words,
you know?
And He's,
they tell me,
this is taking way longer than I thought.
It was.
Just like,
well,
you know,
it's your life.
You don't sweat.
Do it as,
do it as thoroughly as you can.
But I used to tell him to do,
and this is a really good
thing to know as well,
you can write a really bad plan for your
life and that's way better than no plan
at all.
And so if you're going to figure
out what you're going to do,
you're going to be wrong.
And so you don't have to get
all perfectionistic about
it because what the hell
do you know?
You're going to chart your course and
then you're going to move forward in the
world and you're going to occur experience
as a consequence of moving forward.
And then that's good if you would like
to do enough so you be able to make a
better plan.
So all you have to do is make a plant
that's good enough so that it gets you to
your next plan.
And I've also watched people for decades
now they've asked me questions like
that,
but what should I do if
I don't know what to do?
And that's where is don't wait around.
All you do is getting old and you get
old way faster than you think and you'd
like your 25 one day and
then you're 40 the next.
And if you're still 25 when
you're 40 that's an ugly thing.
It's an upbeat and you're not
going to be happy about it.
So make a stupid plan.
And implemented,
get bashed around by the world,
it'll tell you what your plan is
wrong and then you can reformulate it.
And so had freezy off her bed.
It's like,
well,
not that smart and I'm not that wise,
but I can make a tentative
plan as long as I stand back,
watch while I'm implementing it,
maybe I could learn enough
to get to the next step.
And that,
that's fine.
That's perfect.
It's,
so that's a good thing to know.
So the kids really liked that.
And so,
so then I got together with
my partners and we thought,
well,
why don't we try this on a larger scale?
We'll just,
we'll just build an exercise that
people can do online at guided writing
exercise and uh,
let people try it and see what happens.
So we tested it at Mcgill University.
First we did a,
we got these 80 kids who,
who weren't doing well academically.
So they were on academic probation.
Now these are kids who had done pretty
well in university or high school because
they put the got into McGill otherwise,
so they all had an eastern 80 average.
They didn't have
intellectual shortcomings,
but you know the first year or two at
university can be rough because you're
adapting to the transformation
of your life and all of that.
And so then we put the kids into group
one of two groups randomly at one group
was right about you did a bunch of self
analysis exercises and a bunch of a
bunch of writing about who you were,
but it was all like questionnaire base.
And then the other one was this free
writing exercise that was structured but
help you outline what I just
mentioned about your future.
So the rest of the future,
all three exercises.
Okay,
so you answer those,
set the questions,
then you develop a conceptualization of
what you'd like your life to be at three
to five years and you write about that
for 20 minutes and you don't get too
obsessive about it.
Just think,
okay,
if I could have what I needed
to justify my existence,
what would it look like?
And then the second half is,
okay,
well now that you've got
your vision in place,
how about a strategy plan and strategy?
So that that was the whole exercise.
So we had kids in the guilty.
This,
it produced a 30% decline in their
probability of dropping the university.
So that just blew us away.
What was the question?
Hopefully for right,
but at 25% improvement in her.
So pool
but also kind of sad because you think,
well look,
I mean all of that had to happen was these
kids had to have a plan and then I'll
then they weren't like flapping about
uselessly and blowing in the wind.
You think,
would it be good if someone wouldn't be
helping him develop a damn plan for like
a third of the time thing where
it's school so they would just home,
right?
They had a vision of who
they want it to be wide,
how would they were going to take their
place in the world and we're encouraged
to think that that is a worthwhile
endeavor and that there were,
there were,
there were great things to do that they
could be doing even on a local scale,
like being a good husband or
a good wife or a good father,
a good mother.
These are not trivial things are not
trivial things that people should think
about them seriously and they
should take them seriously.
Or to be a good neighbor,
a good friend,
or to be successful in your career,
which is what then,
you know,
we really promote in our
culture and fair enough,
but it's not everything.
So are things to do in the world that
need to be done and there are problems
that need to be solved and there's
enough prompts for everybody.
So,
you know,
it'd be really good if we could
tell our kids to get the hell,
get their act together and get the
hell out there and do something useful.
And it's really good for them to that.
And so,
so then if you get them to do that,
say,
well,
make a plan.
Poof.
There are 30% less likely to
drop out of the university.
So we're pretty happy about this.
But he's a small study,
you know,
40 and 40 maybe it only worked at McGill,
who knows.
So then we went to Holland woman there,
pop the shippers.
She,
she,
uh,
was a professor at the Rotterdam
School of Management and she,
um,
she decided that she would do this with
all the first year business students.
And so there's like a thousand of them.
And so they just did it as
part of a course assignment.
No instruction.
They just have the program
says write about your future.
And so they aren't worried
about their future.
Say thing happened at about
a 30% decline and drop up.
But we did a little bit more
distinct analysis this talk.
So we stratified that the
people into sex and ethnicity,
just a rough cut.
So we use Ben and women and
we used western Westerners,
the Dutch basically Dutch nationals
and non western ethic wine words.
And so that would be four categories.
And then we looked out there their
previous academic achievement.
And so the people who are doing the best
were the Dutch women and then the ducks
ma'am.
And then the non Western ethnic minority
women and then the northern ethnic
Western minority men and the no on
ethnic western on minority net were
underperforming the
women by about 80% wall.
A big difference.
Now there was hundreds of people and
we tested thousands of people in these
samples.
So the samples,
saplings were very stable.
We did it over a number of years.
And so we fucking two things.
The first thing is it had a
bigger effect on men and on women.
Now we think that's because the
women are already doing better.
And so if you're,
if you're kind of set on something and
you have a plaid that maybe making a plan
doesn't help that much,
but if you don't have a plan,
it really helps.
But this was the coolest thing.
Two years after the group
did this study did the,
did the exercise,
the not western ethnic minority men
were outperforming the Dutch women.
So yeah,
yeah.
There were hundreds of
them in this sample.
So it was a robust result.
And so that just blew us away because
for a bunch of reasons was first of all,
well imagine if you're an
immigrant to a new culture,
you're pretty disoriented,
right?
Obviously cause that's
part of being an immigrant.
And so maybe it's even more important
for you to get your bearings and figure
out what you're doing and why.
So about,
so that was,
that's one possible reason.
But the other thing that was
so cool is you always hear,
especially in our culture now with its
idiot political correctness and its
identity,
guess that the reason or
corrupt sociologists,
geological
conditions of the society,
and obviously there's some truth in that
because every society is ethnocentric
at parochial to some degree
in favor of the majority.
It's almost like the
definition of society.
But here we get a psychological
intervention and it
completely obliterated the
sociological effects completely.
And so that was,
that was just,
well,
you know,
you don't as a,
you don't feel like doing a
football touchdown dance very often.
You don't see scientists in the
hallway doing that sort of thing,
you know?
But that was something that we didn't
expect that was really reliable and it was
an absolutely excellent.
And so,
and then recently we did the same
thing at Mohawk college in Canada.
We had the kids come in and get prepared
for university and their orientation,
and they can either do the future
authoring exercise for only 90 minutes.
They just sit down at the
computer and get it cold.
They didn't even know they were going to
be doing it as part of the [inaudible].
Well maybe they have
[inaudible] form only,
only minimally or they get some
other exercise for 90 minutes.
It dropped the dropout rate
of Ben in the first semester.
50% 50% yeah.
So
that part as well.
And so if you have done
very well in high school,
it had a walloping effect on you.
And if you also were in a program
that didn't have like a professional
designation at the end,
so it was like a general arts program,
then it also really had
a whopping effect on you.
So basically it was a program that was
really good for people who have been
doing very well because they were kind
of lost and still hadn't specified a
future 50% decrease in
dropout in the first semester.
So,
okay.
Now the reason I'm telling you
all that for a specific reason,
and the reason is associated with this
rule can be precise in your speech.
Um,
you're not going to get what
you want those to specifier.
That's the first thing.
And there's a real reason for that,
is that like,
you actually create the
world by specifying it in a
much deeper sense than you
think.
So I'll tell you the story about how
psychologists discovered that because this
is one of the great scientific discovery
stories that you would say for the last
20 years.
Some of you probably know
about this experiment already,
but I don't think you necessarily
know how revolutionary it was.
Scott named,
uh,
Dan Simon did these experiments.
He published a paper
called gorillas in that,
in our,
it's a study.